you may not think five thousand dollars
for a gift basket is a lot of money for
an actor but you're also spending this
much at night on a hotel room and in
reality they're going to spend 12 12
hours a day on a set
toward the end of your book what you
don't learn in film school shane you
have this story it's a fascinating story
where you said you saved a hollywood
studio
what 50 million it was about
yeah and it was it was for a very large
trilogy
uh that they were producing at the time
and what had happened is they they had
committed to making three blockbuster
movies you know tent polls over the
course of i think five or six years
and they had tremendous success with the
first one it was it was everything that
they make these kind of movies for and
more and
the second one had come out and not done
very well
and i got a phone call one day from
somebody that i had worked with when i
was doing studio work
and i guess he had talked to one of the
heads of production at this other studio
and said you know you need to kind of
flip the script on your mindset
you really need to get an indie rat to
look at your budget your schedule and
your script and and let somebody go in
with the mindset that understands
production at this level but thinks
thinks you know how do you make
something for a dollar really for a dime
and i got a phone call out of the blue
one day and it was ahead of production
for a studio and they they had me come
in
they wouldn't talk much about it on the
phone it was very hush-hush and covert
everything was in code and i walked into
the boardroom and there was all these
people sitting around a horseshoe table
with you know their fiji bottles of
water and their highlighter pens or
sharpies and their
pads of paper and they had a seat for me
and i couldn't figure out why i was
there and you know one of the the
head-head people came in he was wearing
a suit i remember that
and um told me the situation and what
they were dealing with and how they had
made
really big commitments
going into the third that the second
film's lack of success did not justify
they but they were contractually
obligated to certain escalations in
people's pay
they were shooting in different
countries all over the world
um so they asked if i would um
take a look at the they wanted me to
look at the first two films
then they wanted me to break down the
third one just from my perspective and
it was
it was heavy cgi you know it was a big
tentpole studio movie it's not what i do
but they had me go through everything
and
we
spent a few days i had to do everything
there i wasn't allowed to leave with any
materials my cell phone had to be far
there was a person in the room with me
at all times
and just broke it down and it's just
common sense common sense common sense
and then you know i'd see a way to save
you know
a lot of money and they would tell me no
you can't do that because we have this
contract in place or there are these
agreements with unions or
you know we have to pay these actors
these scales but
it was interesting looking at a budget
for a film that was you know over 200
million dollars
i mean you know when you're making films
that are
comfortably you know in that million
dollar range
and you know you you find a place for
every dime and you make sure it
stretches and you start looking at where
money is going at
dollars
at that level it's mind-blowing you know
the money that's spent wasted that'll
never see the screen you know perk
packages daily per diems and bonuses and
private jets back and forth
hotels that cost a fortune that these
these actors will be in to just sleep a
couple hours you know a few hours a
night
um it's mind-blowing and um
so i i felt very fortunate to be a part
of that process it it reminded me
of
the difference between being an
independent filmmaker and really being
in embedded with the studio system
and this was at a time when when the
studios were just spending so much money
and there i don't think there was a real
checks and balances on where these these
dollars were going it was it's about
give the actors what they need
give the filmmakers what they need you
know above the line producers i think
there were
17 of them 18 of them that's not
including the talent
um you know cinematographers and
high-end
crew i mean there were some really big
crew people on this too and this was a
big film
and i i think
you know looking back
that
i don't think anything's changed with
them you know it's
no surprise that a studio will gladly
spend 200 million dollars to make 20
million i mean that's obviously not the
goal but
that's kind of the business model for a
lot of the studios you know a lot of
people say well 80 of studio films fail
that's true
but
what we deem a failure just because we
look at the domestic box office doesn't
mean globally it was a failure it's a
lot of ways that they can still make
money on ancillaries and different
outlets for their project or you know
plushies and toys and all the stuff that
come with it
but um it was an interesting experience
and it
it really
made me appreciate what
we do as independent filmmakers and and
why i really i think it was an
experience like that because i just come
off of making gridiron gang shortly
before
and was lining up to do some more studio
and network projects
and i remember walking away from that
and just saying you know
sure who wouldn't want a paycheck like
some of these people were getting of
course we who wouldn't
but when it comes down to getting movies
made and loving what you do and who you
do it with
and passion for maybe it's your art
passion for working with the people you
care about or just want to kick a movie
out every year or two
it really it really kind of helped push
me into the direction of just saying you
know what that that isn't
what i want to pursue i want to be able
to find people that want to go
get their hands dirty stretch a buck
shoot where we're not supposed to shoot
shoot with cameras that aren't the
newest or the coolest
and go make fun movies that you know
people may or may not like
it was kind of a life-changing
experience for me
i'm glad we saved the studio a lot of
money i mean it was i couldn't remember
it was 38 or 52. i haven't read that
part of the book in a while
but
there was we saved them a lot of money i
mean
and just common sense money
where was most of the money being spent
that you ended up cutting
um most of the money was um believe it
or not
um
studios spend an outrageous amount of
money in post-production on films like
that
and
they have contracts they have ways that
they're gonna put money into something
from one account into another you know
that that happens when you know they'll
have three edit bays working on one film
that's a walk and talk drama you know
they can have an apprentice editor
setting things up for the assistant
editor the assistant editor setting up
things for the other editor and the
amount of money they're charging for
these
these kit fees and these bungalow
rentals and you know there are there are
union jobs so those pay scales are what
they are unless you're getting an
academy award winner a real hot editor
but what i notice is just
i i know a lot of veterans i mean
editing's my back my background
cgi i've got a lot of people in my life
that do that and when you start
budgeting things and you start getting
teams of 30 40 50 people to do something
that you see you know you can cut this
down you don't have to go this route you
could go to a different country you
don't have a contract with this country
to do post
you can talk to these guys here they
would love your business and probably
cut this most of these things were done
in post and cgi and
just kind of reworking perks i mean it
was even
you know studios have their private jets
they they perk out you know and have
deals with hotels all over the world but
there's only so many jets to go around
so
it was it even got to the point where we
were literally making deals with other
private charter services
and other people that we knew in the
private airline business that were able
to help save a lot of money because you
know flight from la to new york people
don't realize a private plane flight
could cost over 20 grand
it's not a cheap flight so imagine
flying people from la to other parts of
the world
and
trying to just connect dots with
transportation coordinators that weren't
to
bruise any egos but just kind of inform
some of the executives on where they
could go
and
that's what we did now how much money
they ended up
using
on that savings or you know how much
whatever the dollar amount was that we
saved i don't know what they ended up
spending i just know on paper
following all their guidelines and rules
and their
you know what they asked you know us to
adhere to in
putting together a new budget
it was it was pretty substantial you
know for all i know they spent more than
that
uh than the original budget they
probably did but
you know it checked everything checked
out it was doable
and during this meeting
were there certain topics that made them
uncomfortable when you said let's cut
this and we'll do this and we'll move
this over here and you could see oh
that's that's probably not going to work
for them um there's a lot of looking
around you know what i found in in a
system like that is it
there's a pecking order there is a
hierarchy and and is there isn't most
business and
a lot of people um when you'd suggest
something you wouldn't get one person
saying yes or no you get a lot of people
looking to one or two different people
and then looking to another person and
it just ends up going to the head of the
table anyway you know um
so
it's it's rare people are going to go
out on a limb and say that's that's what
we need to do it kind of you know the
ideas always played pinball or would
come back after three or four
discussions to a no or hey that's good
can we try this over there and they were
very
forward thinking once they started
seeing it wasn't like i reinvented the
wheel for them it was just getting them
to just kind of throttle back a little
bit on the hemorrhaging of money on
everything giving everybody everything
okay you have made these commitments to
these actors
i get that but they don't need to know
what you're spending on these things
these gift perks these you know hotel
rooms or
these other perks that go on that these
actors are given
films at that level there's different
ways to
to still give them what you're
contractually obligated to give them and
save and we were getting to the point
where literally saving
two three hundred dollars on every gift
basket i mean that's that's the kind of
stuff we were literally getting down to
we were doing everything we could to
save them money
gift basket so that is a typical thing
on certain sets oh sure sure the studios
treat their actors really well and i i
think even independent filmmakers you
know should if they don't when you get
an actor that shows up on your film
that's you know a special guest i think
i think welcoming them with something
even if it's a fruit basket or a bottle
of nail polish or something is good
but studios you know
they they have some
really
you know and there's a lot of
sponsorship that comes with that too
it's kind of like the oscars but there
is costs there are you know all sorts of
things that go into these things that
cost money everything costs money and
you know when you start going in with
the mindset of okay instead of just
saying you're going to spend five
thousand dollars on every gift basket
and it's going to end up costing you
2500 to 3 500 after you get the free
how do you make them feel equally
special for five or six hundred dollars
and it's it's doable it's just about
taking the time to break it down and not
just throwing the money at the problem
sure and then you said the hotel room
where they may just stay over well yeah
unfortunately there wasn't a lot we
could do with hotel rooms because of
contracts you know various studios and
production entities you know especially
when studios are going to other parts of
the world
there are a lot of setups already so
they're not going to you're not going to
go in and ruffle too many feathers with
that but it's just the cost and it's
reminding them that
you may not think five thousand dollars
for a gift basket is a lot of money for
an actor but you're also spending this
much at night on a hotel room and in
reality they're going to spend 12 12
hours a day on a set
then they're going to be doing this this
this press junket maybe this
and
at the end of the day this is with the
exception of their days off this is
where they're going to hang their head
at night
and how how can some of these things be
worked out and i think most of those
things were kind of finagled more for
not the top tier level of actor but it
was about finding other similar
accommodations that were substantially
lower i mean it's it's not rocket
surgery i mean i've got i've got a
nephews getting married at pebble beach
coming up and they threw us all the
available hotels
and i mean i think the room started 1200
1400 a night and you know
those two things i don't pay for myself
is a nice fancy hotel room and a
first-class airfare you know i'm just
sitting on a plane going from a to b
i'll do a coach i have no problem with
that
um
i made three phone calls and i i i'm
basically five minutes from the wedding
spending 209 a night for the wedding
that's just the mentality that i have
you know i just think there's money that
is better served somewhere else and and
so i that's the mentality i kind of took
with them and everything
and um you know they were receptable to
a lot of the ideas again did they end up
doing it i know i wasn't leaving until i
was able to show them a savings so they
at least
accepted what i presented at the end of
the day
but
i i couldn't tell you what they ended up
spending you never know but i know that
they were they were concerned going in
and needed needed some cuts so i i don't
think they just brought me in to
have me warm a seat for three days
well i don't want to blow my street cred
here but what is an indie rat
i'm an indie rat it's people that just
you know
they don't wait for the machine they
figure out a way you know it's i i
always you know i talk about in the book
is you know give me an actor a camera
and a place to do it and let's go make a
movie it's it's
not waiting for a machine to decide you
know when all the stars align you know i
had when we did gridiron gang
we made that deal i believe in 1993
it was the most sought after property in
hollywood everybody had bid on it but
paramount
and you know hundreds of producers
directors and actors all wanted to be a
part of it and then it gets to the
studio and it took two years to finally
go into turnaround it never got made
and you know
fast forward to 2006
you
know and
i just i know not every film goes
through that but
it's not uncommon
and i had spent some time at a network
after doing gridiron i i was brought on
uh to to develop in-house projects for a
major network with a writing partner of
mine at the time
and we spent i think 13 months there
talking about a lot of great projects
that never got made
and these were passion projects that the
network wanted to do these weren't our
ideas it was we were brought in to do
the passion projects that the high ups
wanted to see get made
and the meetings and the development
discussions and i'll never forget it you
know um
the the vp of the the network brought me
into his office one day after our 100th
you know development meeting on one show
and
it was friday and he said you like
scotch i said i like scotch he poured us
a scotch we put our feet up on his
coffee table and shot the breeze for a
few minutes and he said
you're a filmmaker man you don't belong
here he said i can see your frustration
he said i he's you'll always have an
open door with me
but i think you need to just go out and
make movies he goes this isn't how you
work
i said yeah i just don't understand it i
said we've been here 13 months we've
gone from this project for four months
to oh that's not cool anymore let's jump
on this one oh that's that's not gonna
fit in today's climate and then we go to
something else and i said here we're on
round three in 13 months and we haven't
done anything i said you know my idea is
write something that you're excited
about get some friends together and go
shoot it and that's that's what i do
that's what i believe in
and um i think at that point
i had just gotten to in my life was
where it was about just
just doing what we wanted to do and it
doesn't agree with everybody and not
everybody likes what i do and that's not
why i don't do it for people who like it
i do it because i need to do it to just
to feel alive that's
you know what i need to do
and um it's it's been it's been a lot of
fun and and i wouldn't trade those days
in doing the studio film or you know
working with the networks the way i did
it it taught me so much to be able to do
what i do today
because i can see it from both sides i
can see it from a creative person who
doesn't have a lot of budget to work
with but i also know the end game in
when this thing is done where it has to
go how it how it has to be exploited
around the world
and making sure we check the boxes that
you know all 54 territories and 172
countries that are out there that buy
there's something in it for everybody
how can
the quote-unquote indie rats and the
quote-unquote suits harmoniously work
together
because each needs each other each needs
each other that's a that is a great
question um
i wish i had all the answers and i i'd
like to think i play well with others i
some of the greatest relationships i've
had in this town have been with the
suits
um
and i
p what people we all have to remember
this is a business at the end of the day
but it's like let's take something like
the car business which we talked about
before
you have the people that actually design
the cars that you know
have jobs designing and engineering then
you have the people that actually have
to be the executives behind the decision
to greenlight a car being made and then
you have the car dealerships that are
going to acquire the cars and then you
have the salesmen who have to sell them
and then you got the mechanics who have
to work on them everybody needs each
other it's kind of like on a film set we
have a rule where i don't care if you're
the star of the show if you're a pa
you're all equal to this machine running
in in harmony and we all need to show
respect for one another and i think
i think there's always been a little bit
of a clash between the suits and the the
filmmaker
but i think if if people can get on the
same page
and i think i think if the
executives would trust the artist that
they're
giving their money to or distributing i
think if you fall in love with an idea
you fall in love with the script or a
filmmaker's vision from a previous film
you need to decide i either trust this
person
to run with it or i don't and i think
when you get too many cooks in the
kitchen
i think it stifles the creativity i i
know i've been involved with some pretty
pretty big projects where the suits and
the artists couldn't ever get along it
got very
very intense it got it got explosive at
times even on sets where a studio
exactly show up
not happy with the director for a style
they're shooting in or
unhappy because a dp is moving the
camera too much and
the the tempers that flare on set in
front of everybody i mean you know we
are in a industry of children
whether we like it or not um and i just
i just don't think it needs to be that
way and i think
communication is key it's not just okay
we believe in you you're getting paid go
shoot this movie and then we look at
dailies and we tell you what we like and
don't like and when you start doing that
to an artist it really the hair on the
back of their neck goes up i've seen it
time and time again
and i just think there's
i think there's probably some basic
fundamentals i find a lot of suits spend
a lot of time psychoanalyzing things
they take a lot of classes and body
language how to read somebody's
temperament across the desk or across
the room
and i don't think they've been taught
or maybe there isn't a class maybe when
you make this the next book is basically
how to understand
the inner workings of an artist and what
those buttons are in their life that can
make them
because once that trust has been broken
or once that
that communication has been
derailed i i it's very i don't think
it's something that can come back
did it do the
steeple you know with the hands a lot of
this i'm not talking like this
thinking am i doing that right now no no
i'm just i'm just thinking of like you
know the any any good uh movie with an
executive or something you'll have the
steeple and they'll be thinking watch
phil watch phil joanna's film entropy
i think it's a brilliant film phil
phil's a friend uh he directed great
aaron gang um you know phil it's no
secret phil punched out a studio
executive in front of 300 people on a
set of heaven's prisoner
and um i think he was heaven's prisoner
he did um it was the alec baldwin film
and
you watch what builds to that point
and a lot of people don't believe that
actually happened i can assure you it
did
um
[Music]
and it happens more often than you
realize it may not go to blows as much
anymore i think people are ready for
that now or they they hide behind text
and emails is really what people are
able to do it's that's also a lot of the
face-to-face has been taken out of our
business everything's text messaging and
emails
and you know i think a lot of people do
that out of trying to get it done quick
fear and fear is a big big component of
that because people don't like
confrontation and i think
you know if executives would just
understand that when you trust an
artist's vision and you greenlight him
or her to
to fulfill that promise
that you you really need to just trust
you you know
sidney lumet in his book
said something brilliant about
hiring actors and he said when you're a
director and you make a decision on an
actor
good or bad you have to live with that
decision and you have to do everything
you can to see that
that journey is as smooth as sailing as
possible i can't remember the words he
used but there were times in his career
where he said that he really thought he
had the right actor for a role and
realized on day one
in rehearsal that this was the biggest
mistake of his life
and
you would never know it as an audience
member you would never know it as maybe
the actor who he hired but it's it's
about understanding the being that
you're working with and artists are
fragile we're very sensitive to
everything
we take everything personally you know
if somebody doesn't like a cut or
somebody doesn't like
you know the theme of something or the
style
it's it's it's a personal attack it's
never separated
and
it takes a strong artist to be able to
do that and i think it takes a stronger
executive to be able to really find a
way to communicate with people
on how to get the adjustments the studio
or network might need to get what they
need
and i i've really seen it done in a
productive way that's just me
sure and i agree with what you're saying
about being sensitive but i think also
too some of the quote unquote suits and
i wish i could find a better word for
them but um they're also sensitive in
that they don't like being told no and
they don't like people usurping their
authority or or challenging them
especially if they believe in this
pecking order and there's a lot of fear
i think there's fear from both you know
what hollywood fear and love okay so so
fear
fear from both sides and so just
thinking about what are ways that you
know there could we could prevent a blow
up if if one is mirrored in a pecking
order mindset and well i can't believe
you would tell me what to do you don't
you know who i am and then there's this
artist don't you know what i've done and
i can't believe you would doubt me and
then the clash that happens yeah and
it's ego driven
at the end of the day i mean it's fear
driven and it's ego driven because
you know in our business it's it's
literally you know your career could be
made or broken in in one project you're
either the next
damian chazelle
or
you know you make a mistake and you
don't have a hit you're done i mean you
know
look what happened to uh george
casamatos you know he came off of god
rest him he was a great filmmaker i mean
look at what tombstone he did tombstone
and he was
you know the next greatest thing and i
worked with him on shadow conspiracy
with charlie sheen which was i think the
last film he ever did and i can assure
you that's not what he wanted to go six
feet under with his name on
and i don't think he would have worked
much after that film no disrespect but
not saying i could do anything better
i'm just saying when you look at how
fast you can turn around you know
um
you know some great filmmakers and
actors in this industry that have hits
that people just they're just bowled
over with
and
they do a couple more films and what
happens to them and it's unfair
you know one of my favorite filmmakers
of all time is mike figgis i mean i
admire him because here's a guy who
writes directs produces edits composes
caters
you know probably cleans the latrine i
mean that guy is a filmmaker's filmmaker
and obviously when he had leaving las
vegas with
you know nicholas cage and
elizabeth shu and all the oscar
accolades that came with it
how do you deny somebody like that you
know this guy's gonna do it again you
know solomon king went through the same
thing you know he had a string of hits
and then had some that that weren't as
successful and you know
and um it's it's you know i guess it's
like that in sports it's like that in in
a lot of businesses i mean i don't know
it seems like people can in the suit
side it seems like people can run
companies into the ground over and over
again and still
end up running other companies but
we see that a lot but i think i think
the artists and the executives i think
need to
find a way
to
to spend more time understanding one
another and not just thinking they
understand one another you know we
forget that you know i always go back to
the record industry
and and you know when when music was you
know a business back in the earlier days
of a r representatives working for
labels and seeking bands and clubs that
nobody heard of and
watching that that machine grow into
becoming something that was worthy of
signing to a major label
i knew a lot of a r guys back in the 80s
and 90s because of my music background
and i used to say to them you know
how do you not get fired and they said
we say no
you don't sign a ban you don't get fired
and studios have to crank out so many
films a year production companies have
to fulfill the machine especially now
because it's a bottomless pit right you
know if
you know how many productions are
getting made at netflix at any given
time it's 33 i think right now
so there's a machine that needs to be
filled
but
i think they understand each other from
a very generic standpoint i still don't
think they've found a way to really melt
into
you know harmonious relationships it's
very rare
it's very rare
you